Avengers endgame the highest-grossing
movie of all time
did not win the Oscar for Best Visual
Effects so what is the title of
highest-grossing movie of all time even
me if it didn't win a single Oscar is it
even worthwhile movie quarter crew has
done a VFX artists react to Avengers and
game batting great CGI I personally
think it's your one that's my personal
belief that's what I was rooting for I
knew it wasn't going to but I thought it
should there were a couple of
innovations in the way that we
approached Ellison social work in a
shockwave we had one version that was
much bigger
maybe you've discovered something that
we didn't even team to put in the movie
wait they got the actual VFX guys
welcome back to another very special day
is gonna be like visual effects
supervisors at Wetty and it's an
incredible honor to have him here on the
show so work on a ton of movies I
thinking from Avengers endgame all the
way back to Lord of the Rings using our
Lord orys special I'm the guy standing
the head with the really early laser
sterilizer
my role is that I'm the kind of the
contact point between the team at where
the digital you know producing the
visual effects work on a given show and
the people at the studio like well with
the team at Marvel on the Avengers films
I'm hoping you know the finished visual
picture it's supposed to go to the movie
it's like when you go to the dentist and
you're like the nurse that like works
for a while your teeth and the dentist
comes in just like touches everything
briefly at the very end is that you
basically possibly
Oh endgame was actually nominated for an
Academy Award for Best Visual Effects
we're also nominated for the BAFTA which
is the British Academy of Film and
Television Awards so I get to fly in on
London go to the back doesn't then come
back here next week for the Oscars city
[Music]
for guys this is part of the campaign
when the scenes I guess respected former
student game was good climactic and
battle scene yeah that was pretty much
what we did I worked started when a law
students happened in the eighth ship and
destroys the Avengers compound and we go
all the way through to Tony and his
giant explosion we worked a lot because
I had to look like it was really create
this huge crater but at the same time it
could look like it just believed it was
much bigger they were like no by
comparison
we shared the shot with Ireland so the
certain point here it becomes
Annihilator
they did all this work here we did all
that the outside stuff you should talk
to them which I'd like to cover as well
I'm always impressed by the level of
consistency delivering the same
character yeah the team at Marvel they
do a lot of work in terms of giving us
each notes will show a version of laughs
and they're like aspects of it they'll
take that shot and show it to Dedes and
you know we'll share geometry and we'll
share textures you know that completely
different assets so there are two
completely different 3d models of Thanos
yep that are brought up to the exact
same level of quality so you can't tell
the difference between them well that's
what we try to achieve if you enjoyed
the show and you want to keep watching
well please consider subscribing so that
it shows up in your subscription feed
and you never miss an episode the other
half was wrong so when you have a
character like Stannis
it was completely digital but obviously
driven by a real actor what are the main
steps between him acting and what we
finally see in the movie we were your
suit that's market up so we'll get his
body performance from there and we'll
also dot up his face he'll be wearing a
hit belted camera rig without filming
the dots on his face as he performs
often what we do is we'll do motion
capture as having at the same time as
the live action photography so through
infrared motion capture we can capture
the suit dots without polluting the
light if the director of photography is
creating on the sphere
misunderstand fellowship extra works and
movies they just kind of assume that the
motion is captured and then just applied
to a 3d model and that's all you have to
do amazing
though she kept a really place to create
his movement but the number of times
that we have rural motion capture data
going up to thousands ero to just find
10 offs and the motion capture
performance that's why any service that
went we're addicted Josh I've got the
more dramatic movements and we're motion
capturing the stunt II and even then he
still never moved the same way as an
eight-foot-tall muscle-bound their most
removes hair the fantastic animation
supervisor on Twitter said the combo can
told her he would dial in what he would
call the body mechanic off their off so
he's getting the white and maybe slowing
down the movement in there yeah
something that will keyframe on top of
the motion capture data as well in
you're doing if there's much armor on a
character can be really hard to animate
all of it and have it move correctly and
slide over itself without clipping yeah
this one shot is love you can see it's
finger bits through the yeah I would
caught it at the time so there's always
a little bit more than bad CGI you don't
want to constrain what Josh is doing on
set you want him to be able to perform
and then you just have to make the amur
work to that so there's a lot of sleight
of hand going on bending of things that
should be rigid it's a thing of craft
you know bringing an ASUS hands on
to sculpt that suit enjoy very very much
we talked about panels this case for
mullen sure do the poorest stretch there
are a couple of innovations in the way
that we approached hair loss the spatial
work up until infinity war we would
expect from the facial motion capture of
Josh to the performance of their off
well we started doing our infinity war
was introducing this intermediary step
which we call the active pattern we've
got the footage of Josh from the head
mounted cameras we've got a digital Josh
and then with our digital panel and we
can see very clearly if it's deviating a
little bit from what John is doing and
then throwing looks like a mortal comic
[Music]
look at the eyes that's not the look for
the sysm of digital performance if it's
not working the eyes look did so we have
to get the eyes right and we spend a lot
of time lighting the eyes so that they
have a nice highlight so you're a
special life and the scene and it's a
little small area light but quite bright
in the eyes will pick it up it'll have a
very subtle effect over the wrist of
whom
so green see you guys are using models
of three than this as well as
rotoscoping
yeah how are you eating such perfect
edges in your green screen I mean a good
green screen so well lit and they're
clean and then we've got a lot of really
kind of life techniques we're doing
parts of the hair differently you know
if we get something really gnarly you
might have to net remove in a digital
version of the actor and replace the
plate here with really CG here for a
brief moment yeah I'm gonna tell the
flip I think that's just a warp actually
and I think she might have flicked ahead
it's the how the duck show like I want
to be going to get how the duck of the
movie somewhere so we had to migrate
possession I sent house to how the dark
lure head down that the guardians to the
game when the ravaging guns just way too
big for them
notice that each of those portals have
like a different color scheme inside of
it and it represented the Infinity
Gauntlet you guys react any sad schools
or TV shows please leave a comment in
the description below and let us know
and we will take a look at get a
Birdemic episode I don't think anyone's
ever seen so many like heroes on screen
at a single time the filmmakers you know
they managed to balance all that stuff
so that it's personal a lot of it is as
these little beats you know and we get
these character moments of Tony and
Spidey it's the stuff that makes it
successful you know we were just really
there supporting these these fantastic
character moments this entire sequence
that would have worked on what do you
think was probably the most challenging
single shot of the entire sequence
there's a little shot called the winner
it was the most scary part of the cap
for a long time for me but now I can
enjoy it
amazing shot
so many layers of complexity everything
from clashing on these two levels to
animation do you like yeah and CG at the
same time we have 70 now working on the
animation supervisor at Sony animation
team who are building the elements of
the shot populating the scene we're
iterating the whole time so as soon as
there's anything that's even a
half-decent we'll pass that down the
line to two Lighting's all that lighting
work is going on at the same time as the
animation work or three months yeah this
is that the characters a room lit by
their sound yeah this definitely did not
deserve the lighting position going into
a lot of this stuff one thing we do do
which is what they tell you what they
did hit on location is don't worry about
the any sort of consistency to the
position of the Sun the key light so
they'll always put that behind the the
character that they're filming the thing
I like to show people that really
explains that is a scene from the very
end of the first Independence Day movie
[Music]
for the shadows we try and adopt these
principles because they're established
cinematographic principles that work
these things here they actually film on
a practical set but you end up having to
replace any of the foreground elements
yes sometimes we do there's a little bit
of a suit helmet behind these guys here
which we kept because it was appropriate
but we did this thing where we
essentially lifted the actors off it and
put them with a predominantly CG of
violence so you basically cut out each
character and none of the background is
real just the characters are real
exactly guys obviously Tony didn't
deserve a yeah so whenever we see him by
himself really the only thing we're
keeping us is here anyway
this is the last shot that we delivered
on the show Wow the thing that was
really important in the end was showing
that Tony is suffering all as damage it
tells me it's going to kill him and so
we had to know that he was making a huge
sacrifice but also it couldn't be so
flashy there that distracted away from
his before we had some of those those
acts of energy pulling one up into a
space ball and it was like each looked
at that he didn't look at them right you
really have to be with him in you've got
to be with them exactly notice that's
all right right there on the cheek pad
so if you think you guys had a big
creative challenge here with Iron Man
dying that you need to show the wounds
are fatal but you can't be so gory or
grisly I said a family killed exactly
and that was something we explored for a
long time through concept art to start
off with it's a little bit similar to
the snap we have to allow him to retain
his dignity through this through this
moment how much of this was a makeup
personal it's entirely digital so I
didn't make up on him on set it off
exactly to do it right because if they
had put prostates is him essentially
they would have been locked in to that
look yeah any more flexibility by doing
it digitally especially when you know
you can achieve a photorealistic result
yeah oh yeah there's a relies on there I
read that most of the moons are actually
just two-dimensional tracks supposed to
fall 3d yeah exactly
we met removed his head but we found
that his facial performance was so
subtle that we could just using like
optical flow type techniques warp the
digital panic onto the movement off of
his face so he didn't have to try and
mess with his facial performance the
other thing was for you to sit on the
secret for six or eight months and it
was like oh my god this leaks we can
keep a secret here we've never had a
leak touchwood
we just have to get get down into it and
they were totally on board with us and
it was a total surprise for for
audiences worldwide can you speak about
anything coming up down the pipeline at
whether we're working on the Black Widow
movie which opens soon we you know we
have an ongoing relationship with with
Marvel and it's fantastic you know the
work that they they get us engage them
is challenging and diverse and you know
they're great films there's this this
great kind of like storytelling that's
going on with the MCU that it's just
really exciting to be part of wow that's
been a crazy episode they're getting all
this information straight from the
source
Oh guessing so they actually hear a true
professional like say exactly how you
achieve some of these incredible results
is really cool to hear have you ever
watched some of your stuff and you guys
are pretty onto it so go check out their
website you know as Lena fxc onz there's
articles on how some of these effects
are done lots of great information so do
not discount just going and checking out
that website it's great to be here thank
you Matt I really appreciate it how do
you direct any of this if you don't have
like what level of understanding was the
Russo brothers have on visual effects in
order to direct any of this I I mean I
can't wrap my head around that yeah I'm
sure they change but I'm sure they have
a ton of storyboard rivas and concept
art I just can't imagine how you map all
your shots in these places that have
practical elements but are surrounded by
green screens you're probably not gonna
use any of the practical elements things
together and then it composed these
fluid shots that move you said that one
or shot that has so much going on in it
and so many layers and so much that
appears to be not what was actually in
the room they sure yeah it is mind
blowing really what they're able to
achieve I'm really not just saying it to
like pander to audiences I really
thought this film should have one when I
was watching the Oscars I was like 19 17
is undoubtedly gonna win that's what I
put my boat down for but I was like I'm
hoping I'm wrong and I'm hoping Avengers
endgame does take the Oscar for this I
think the reason why some of the 19:17
probably took it you can't really tell
when there's visual effects on-screen we
movie-like endgame has so much visual
effects that there are times where
you're like that doesn't look entirely
real the flip side though there's so
much in here I'm not even sure what at
times what is visual effects and what is
practical I mean there's they didn't
comment on it here but there's even a
little moment when they're talking about
Thanos and the mocap suit and they're
showing the stunt double for Thanos and
they're and the guy doing cap cap
there's no way he's like throwing a
shield around her net and a hammer but
when they're showing the footage like
he's not even holding anything yeah
they're inserting all those things and I
thought there'll be at least some
practical stuff there or even the fact
of how they were talking like with Tony
Stark in the suit that yeah they put him
in the suit and they're filming there on
set but really all they're taking is
just his head primarily oh yeah just for
the motions they built this world to
life honestly I don't think this movie
would have been as big of a hit if we
were all pulled out by this grand finale
going this looks fake you know there's a
reason why it's so effective yes the
personal moments that are talking about
it what makes it work so well and how
VFX are in support of that at the same
time though I'm like they built so many
things here that for the most part I
couldn't tell when things were practical
when things were not and they
interviewed another visual effects
artist when they talked about like cap
versus cap scene and how they don't that
whole set out of visual effects this
movie was the one that ultimately
deserved the award because of how much
inventiveness and imagination was put
forth to make this work especially when
they're talking about working against
the clock in like a couple of months out
they have to like do some last-minute
things mmm very impressive stuff I'm
torn on this too because I don't know
which angle to approach it from I feel
like there is something to be said for
that idea that some of the best CG is
the CG you have no idea was even there
to begin with and so for Avengers
endgame I can see that maybe being some
kind of kneecap in the sense that it's
like I am NOT sitting there watching
that movie thinking about the CG but I'm
never not aware there's a load of CG at
all times in these parts and one thing
I've learned about this kind of thing is
that also like every movie now has way
more CG than you would expect to build
the world to change landscapes to change
architecture and stuff but that being
said endgame does seem like an
achievement in just the sheer scope of
techniques they're using the sheer
of different shoot days they must have
been stitching together and organizing
and keeping moving while we can debate
which is more merit abulia no just you
know a vast array of complex effects or
effects that you have no idea about I
think there's no arguing that a movie
like this is an achievement and I really
really hope because effects artists VFX
artists especially are kind of
notoriously undervalued in the industry
I really hope that like a 25 visual fix
houses it'll provide all the effects for
this movie were compensated properly
because that's the other thing too is
for these scale movies you have a whole
bunch of people working simultaneously
and that's something that I thought was
really interesting about this video too
is they said like okay we've got our
model of Thanos but then Industrial
Light and Magic has theirs and then we
gotta send information to them and they
send a little information back we gotta
make sure everything matches very
beginning that we're talking about there
was that one shot where it goes into
like an ILM shop this was stuff like one
smooth shot I think the VFX artists are
being more recognized channels like
court or crew make up the huge
difference I think it's because the clip
hand ghovat a nose that's why it didn't
win that's the unreason one camera like
oh my god we found the mistake that's
what it is found it that's what it is
Realty notice it found it and then you
know Mark Ruffalo's head in that
Hulkbuster you know a little Bob Lee in
that last movie so we can't I thought
that was interesting too about the
digital makeup that they did on Tony
Stark's face because I thought that
would have been practical at least in
some part and it seems like so much of
every Iron Man performance it's probably
just his head stitched on and then it's
severely edited even Iron Man one where
he's mainly Tony Stark yeah that's he's
honest stitched on to a suit the whole
thing in the case oh yeah you know
little Armani suit yeah a big thing of
what they were talking about even with
the mocap performances CGI performances
is in the eyes that's like the biggest
thing as a matter of fact one of the
distracting elements to me and this is a
different kind of VFX was in the
Irishman with De Niro's eyes I know it's
a different color than his natural eye
color but there was something in his
eyes I just felt too uncanny to me and
that's what would kind of pull me out
for like the first hour of the film was
right here that's a it's actually not a
point I've really thought about but
truly that does make a
difference I've heard with actors
especially like when I would watch
documentaries about James Dean or he
talks about Ryan Gosling is so much of
performance is really within the eyes
it's like a lens into the soul if
anything you got to get down right I can
imagine the eyes are the most important
thing and then when they were showing
clips of bad CGI I was like oh yeah I
guess the main kid's not everything but
one of the most important integral
ingredients would have to be the eyes
and I loved what they were saying about
Tony Stark's snap you know I've seen the
movie like four times now and I've never
actually I'm so focused on his
performance and his eyes and the glove
that I've never actually noticed the
electricity like running up his neck and
she i'm glad then you to dial it back on
certain things because it could
ultimately pull you out and be
distracting like what you were talking
about with the makeup on his death scene
I thought that was some practical
effects and then they shows behind the
scenes footage Jesus in a black shirt
dotson triangle and again I got to say
something as subtle of a performance as
that moment is a lot of credit goes to
the actors as well for helping to bring
a lot of this to life they have no idea
how a lot of this is actually gonna look
by the time it's all said and done but
they really brought that moment
especially the life cuz that looked
practical effects to me at least some of
it did I thought the suit was a little
CGI but I thought all of this was
practical yeah I would have to looking
back at all these Robert Zemeckis
animated movies that's the one gripe
everybody says dead eyes is like the big
thing about yeah CG faces and so to see
them adjusting the light and what
lengths they go to there one thing that
I just hadn't ever thought of but it
makes total sense is yeah and all those
motion capture performances it's not
just slapping a model on top of the
motion and being not stuck ale yeah it's
like you've got to go in and you've got
a a probably tweaked the performance
information you already got because it's
probably already gonna be some stuff
that's a little janky here and there and
then yeah change physics and they showed
that I think and more the other videos
with the Hulk where they have like an
actor with like a big Hulk head and
shoulders on his head and shoulders and
then there's yeah using that for scope
and scale and stuff and yeah the amount
of like forethought that goes into these
things must be staggering
even in the Tonys s scene you see like
war machine Don Cheadle here in the
behind the scenes just Don Cheadle
putting his arm up against him
then they gotta put this giant I have
food or machine ham right there in the
shot and they have to do that throughout
this whole thing dealing with scale I
had never really put together in mine
but it makes me kind of wonder how when
they would do mocap for characters like
you know Smeagol or Smaug things like
that anyway this is great they
definitely did not talk about the bad
CGI that much because they had that
flippin is we got one in there justified
the title and this segment and bad and
worse a game great CGI it and a moment
get a pissed-off intern to come in for
the next video he was like fired from
better yeah because I was like go for
bad CGI they're the moments that pulled
me out were very early on in this movie
that was when you first start seeing
Thanos on the farm
he looked incredibly digital to me when
he just has like his shirt on in his
arms like there are certain shots there
that look not realistic to me I thought
they were might they might talk about
that moment but you know I can't can't
acknowledge right now when the guys
right there yeah all the moments we
truly could have improved given more
time and resources alright guys what you
think of this video corridor crew thanks
for putting this bad boy together one of
these days you guys would be working on
the huge films as well one of my
favorite moments of this was when the
VFX artists for Men game was saying I've
seen a few of you guys videos and you
guys are usually on point that's a great
sign right there
subscribe to Korra to crew make sure to
subscribe to the reel rejects click that
notifications rather get notified
whenever we got a youtube video up last
but not least
Lance door buddy wanted to make sure to
shout you out on this one because when
we covered the other Avengers hanging
and visual effects video that was
specifically your request which opened
up my eyes to how much VFX was on
display when I didn't even realize it
was so thank you for that Lance is
getting married this year I've been
doing some poem shout outs what I call
my core artistic integrity are these
poetry shout outs right here sometimes I
make weird jokey ones that don't make
any sense I wrote you a sincere one I am
excited for your wedding Lance I'm
excited for your wedding dance the knot
will be tied would your bride-to-be nut
tie or natete let's go in that time
vowing to be together
till one of you does die as she takes on
the surname of door I hope your love
does soar that it's filled with love and
thunder like thor for i hope you to stay
on the right course and that it never
ends in divorce that being said in the
case of a breakup make sure to get a
prenup I know a great lawyer but I also
know a great caterer
whichever one you need we can book them
on your calendar great work done watch
marriage story